et vous aujourd'hui vous êtes dit j'ai
fait de grosses études on était sûr de
trouver du taf et finalement oui mais
moi je pense que ça serait important de
demander aux universités aussi de
d'inclure dans leur programme d'études
beaucoup plus d'expérience
professionnelle
parce que nous on nous disait à nous pré
rentrée de m master 1 et master 2 vous
n'êtes pas là pour faire des stages
avoir une expérience professionnelle
vous êtes là pour écrire votre mémoire
bien mémoire c'est chouette mais avait
regagné sa vie on trouve pas de travail
varient mais pourquoi les entreprises
pourquoi justement les universités des
écoles
elle a raison de dire pourquoi elle se
met pas tout de suite en relation avec
des sociétés qui sont kiki qui
correspondent à ce que lascaux recherche
les jeunes et qu' il dise voilà où on a
des gens va proposer c'est vrai que
c'est on a l'impression que quand on
sort d'une école ou une fac on est à la
rue on est jeté en fait c'est terminé on
a fait son mémoire est terminé on se
retrouve
voilà livrés à nous mêmes alors que pour
quoi on mettrait pas des jeunes en
relation et c'est vrai que ça c'est
c'est eh je trouve que c'est c'est
bizarre je trouve que ça ça devrait de
fait parce que elle elle aurait
peut-être pu trouver ils meurent exemple
le directeur de master
nous on n'est absolument pas accompagné
à
être insérée dans le monde du travail
c'est un stage ou après et en fait il ya
aussi beaucoup de gens qui vont à la fac
parce que c'est presque gratuit et que
c'est une solution de facilité aussi
pour étudier mais le problème c'est que
l'université c'est une formation qui est
très académique
donc on apprend beau c'est la même chose
de très belles théories mais rien
pratiquement être utilisé dans le monde
du travail
alors pour vous je sais que j'ai j'ai
peut-être un mentor pour vous il va nier
bien nous rejoindre j'espère que c'est
un boulanger alors c'est sébastien de
gasquet
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci d'être là c'est un bonheur alors
qui est sébastien sébastien meurant
sébastien s'est battu on dirait qu'il va
nous chanter une chanson dans un piano
bar année lui la guitare c'est le
nouveau kenji celui-ci sébastien merci
d'être là justement pourquoi guitare
pourquoi je parle musique parce que vous
êtes le directeur général adjoint et
secrétaire général d'universal music
france
ouais voilà là je sens que la cami elle
à ses yeux qui brillent aujourd'hui vous
avez une nouvelle alors je rappelle
universal music france et booba c'est
mylène farmer c'est da juiceman et sa
part a dit c'est wade n ai fait qu est
ce qu on s'éloigne c'est michel sardou
qui se faisait à proposer à haqqani
alors j'ai écouté camille et surtout
j'avais regardé son cv avant de venir
puisque nous là on l'a passée maison
sérieuse c'est une maison qui
travaillent bien ce que je vais proposer
à camille c'est dès la semaine prochaine
un entretien avec notre équipe rh pour
faire le point sur ces attentes sont nés
ces expériences parce qu'elle a déjà pas
mal d'expérience dans l'événementiel
dans la programmation et vous serez son
manteau oui je serai son mentor
personnes vous avez votre mentor déjà à
l'âge où ils occupent drh aussi donc
c'est bien elle sera en bonne heure mais
avec un auteur comme ça on est bien et
ensuite on va lui faire rencontrer tous
les métiers de la boîte
aujourd'hui je le dis y'a pas de job qui
correspond exactement à t as ta
formation à tes compétences mais on va
te faire rencontrer tous les gens qui
sont susceptibles de recruter dans les
mois qui viennent sur les différents
métiers d'une maison disque la promo le
marketing l'événementiel aussi puisqu'on
fait d'événementiel
mais je dis ce soir voilà ce qu'un
exemple parce qu'on veut montrer aussi
ce que c'est que le mentorat vous avez
dit à cent mille mentor qui vont arriver
c'est aussi pour vous pousser à aller
sur le site et à trouver un mentor voilà
ce soir aussi vous vous avez la chance
d'être sous le plateau je le redis il ya
plein de gens qui nous regardent et qui
lisent bas nous on aurait bien aimé être
à la place de camille donc aller sur le
site on va dire un il ya cent mille
mentor qui vous attendent et peut-être
qu'ils vont vous aiguiller vous donner
des conseils et peut-être même vous
recrutez peut-être dire aussi que on est
bien conscients enfin moi je suis bien
consciente que une fois qu'on a son
diplôme à l'université on n'a pas
forcément tous les codes pour s'adresser
aux entreprises pour faire le cv dans la
forme qui va bien pour passer des
entretiens d'embauché et pour les jeunes
diplômés
on a mis en place avec l'apec agence
pour l'emploi des cadres
un programme pour accompagner les jeunes
diplômés d'abord leur montrer qu'ils
sont pas tout seuls à avoir des
difficultés c'est vrai qu'avec la crise
c'est plus difficile et il faut pas que
un jeune qui a envoyé 400 cv se
découragent donc je pense que c'est bien
de voir qu'il ya d'autres jeunes qui ont
des difficultés puis s'agit pas juste de
partager qu'on a des difficultés mais il
s'agit aussi d'être aidés pour justement
faire des entretiens d'embauché
préparait son cv et des aussi sur la
façon de rechercher donc ça on l'a mis
en place et puis par ailleurs on a aussi
mis en place et je me réjouis de pouvoir
le dire parce que ce dispositif il n'est
pas assez connu une aide financière pour
les jeunes diplômés ex boursiers c'est
une aide qui est proposé par pôle emploi
pendant quatre mois vous avez 70 % du
montant de votre bourhis au vent